Second wave feminists I've talked
to, they're very
worried about the woke
gender identity movement because
it's reducing women to
just body parts.
Like a guy can say, Well, if I just
get breast implants and I can have a
vaginal plastic made out of a piece
of my skin, then I'm
in. I'm the woman, right?
It's like, well, no, because
women are not just tits and
ass, right? I mean, there's more to
it than that.
For decades, Michael Shermer has
been one of the most popular and
provocative explicator of science
to popular audiences.
Having authored bestselling books
such as Why People Believe Weird
Things, Why Darwin Matters,
The Moral Arc and the Mind
of the Market.
He founded Skeptic magazine in 1992,
hosts a video podcast with leading
activists and intellectuals and for
nearly 20 years authored
a widely read column for Scientific
American in which he debunked
beliefs in UFOs and other
paranormal phenomena, explained the
rise of the new atheism and
showed how evolution systematically
informs human behavior.
Shermer's work is deeply and
explicitly rooted in libertarian
and enlightenment ideas about
individual responsibility, free
market economics, rationality
and the search for something
approaching objective truth.
In 2019, Scientific
American cut him loose, a move
he ascribes to the publication
suffocating embrace of the
sort of identity politics and
wokeness that he says dominates
academic circles and increasingly
the culture at large.
Last fall, Shermer, who holds a
Ph.D. in the history of science and
teaches skepticism 1 to 1
at Chapman University, started a
weekly substack where he hosts
podcasts and the columns he would
have written for Scientific
American. The 67 year old
former competitive cyclist talked
with Reason during Freedom Fest, an
annual gathering in Las Vegas, about
the fundamental clash between
wokeness and scientific inquiry,
how hard it is to overcome the
cognitive biases we all
have. Why he thinks trans
athletes should be banned from most
women's sports.
Why we have so much trouble
acknowledging moral and
technological progress.
And why he now identifies as a
classical liberal rather
than as a libertarian.
Michael Shermer, thanks for talking
to Reason.
Nice to see you again.
So you last year.
Last fall, you started a Substack
publication to go along with Skeptic
magazine and whatnot.
And one of the early pieces was
titled "Scientific American Goes
Woke." And you were a longtime
columnist for Scientific American,
a very popular
science communicator.
What?
Describe what you wrote about
in "Scientific American Goes Woke"
and why you started a Substack.
Right. So I started Scientific
American in 2001 and
I worked almost 18 years, 214
consecutive monthly columns.
I was going for Steve Gould's 300
that he did in Natural History
Museum, which would have taken me
to April 2025, so I didn't quite
make that. Yeah, they terminated the
column. You know, there was no
particular reason given other than,
well, we're going different ways.
And, you know, it's just it's time
for a change.
You know, they didn't say, hey,
we've gone woke and you're an old,
old guy, right?
So yeah, but I could kind of see the
writing in the wall, last couple of
columns I had written.
We're dealing with some issues
kind of related to race and
and sex and gender and that
sort of thing. And I could
feel the uncomfortableness
in the editorial process
and then boom, you know, they they
let it go.
So, I mean, I don't know for sure,
but that that was it.
So I, I started the substack
just because I still had
more writing in me.
I like writing the columns,
but this gives me a little more
flexibility if I want to go more
than 700 words like no
more and. Right, you know, and
also the new media try to keep up
with, you know, I have a podcast and
what everybody's what all the kids
are doing these yeah yeah it's hard
to hard to know what's the right
path to take. But it seemed like the
substack thing was a way to go.
The finances for it,
you know, are channeled through the
skeptic society, which is kind of my
day job.
You know, so the first one, you
know, Scientific American goes,
well, I recounted my
own experiences, but also
I went through a
bunch of articles they had published
recently that were clearly
what most people would identify
as sort of a Far-Left woke
progressive politics.
And one of the most,
you know, notorious or
discussed pieces had to do
with E.O. Wilson being
a racist.
Right. Being a scientific racist.
He's wrote the book Sociobiology.
He you know, in a lot of ways,
you know, his vision of taking
evolution and seriously
applying it or trying to apply to
human society and whatnot had
always been a fraught project.
Right. I mean, he was getting
pitchers of water poured over him
in the seventies at conferences.
Yeah, but that
could you talk a little bit about
that.